- [Voiceover] What I want
to talk about in this video
is the liter.
The liter. Let me write this down.
The liter and the liter
is a unit for measuring fluid volumes,
or how much space does a fluid take up.
So what does one liter look like?
Well one of these milk bottles
is a liter and your most typically
going to think about a
liter in your everyday life
when your buying some type
of beverages, milk, or water.
In fact next time you
go to the grocery store
see a lot of the bottles you get.
They might be exactly one
liter, some of the soda bottles
are two liters, but this
right over here is one.
One liter, we write a capital
L for short, that's one liter
and so there's six liters in total
in this little carrying case
but each of these milk
bottles is one liter.
So that's a liter but
what if we want to go
to really small volumes of water?
Well if we want to go to
really small volumes of water
we normally talk about milliliters.
Milliliters, let me write this down.
Milli
Milliliters. Actually
let me write it this way.
Let me write milli in another color.
Milli
Milliliters.
So it's a milli liter.
And a milliliter, a milli is a prefix
that you'll see a lot
when your using units
and that means one
one-thousandth of a liter.
So this means one one-thousandth.
One one-thousandth of
Of a
of a liter
and the notation for milliliter
is a lowercase m and and uppercase L.
Milli liter.
Another way to think
about it, it would take
one thousand milliliters
to get to one liter.
So what does a milliliter look like?
Well if you imagine
these medicine droppers,
a milliliter would be about that high
on one of those medicine droppers
and a lot of these medicine droppers
actually will have a milliliter,
actually they'll have
up to five milliliters
marked off but a milliliter
will be about that much
or if you were to take a teaspoon
from your cabinet in your kitchen
and you would scoop out
a teaspoon of water,
that, so this one over here
is going to be one milliliter
and a teaspoon of fluid,
that's going to be about five.
That's going to be about five milliliters.
So another way to think about it is
you would have to take a
thousand of these drops
to fill one of these bottles of milk.
A thousand milliliters to get to one liter
or you would have to do, let's see, five,
you'd have to put five,
sorry, you'd have to do
two hundred teaspoons
of say milk, to fill up this entire thing
because each of them is five milliliters.
Two hundred times five milliliters,
you're going to have
a thousand milliliters
which is one liter.
Let me write this down.
This right over here, this is one liter
which is the same thing as one thousand,
one thousand milliliters.
Now what if we go to
things that are much larger.
What if we go to things
that are much larger
than the scale
of a jar of milk.
Say a swimming pool and
this right over here,
this is a picture of a
olympic size swimming pool
which is, for the most
part, the largest pools,
well there some larger pools
in some fancy hotel and things,
but they're very large pools.
So what do you think would be
if one milk bottle
has a, one like this,
has a fluid volume of one liter,
what do you think about
a whole swimming pool?
Well actually a swimming like this,
if it is 25 meters wide and 50 meters long
and two meters deep,
it actually would have
a fluid volume, are you ready for this?
It would have a fluid volume
of 2.5 million liters.
So if you filled this up with
milk, you can use that milk
to fill up 2.5 million of these bottles.
So that's just an appreciation
for just how much fluid
it would take to fill up at least
a big swimming pool like this,
an olympic size swimming pool.
A swimming pool that you
might more typically see
at someone's house, who isn't, you know,
that doesn't have an
olympic size swimming pool
so kinda of a house size swimming pool,
it's still going to be,
it's not usually to see
one that will be more than one hundred,
100,000
100,000 liters.
So once again, are you
thinking about teaspoons
or drops from a dropper,
your thinking in the milliliter range.
If you're thinking about the type of,
something that you might drink in a day
or that your family might
drink over, say a week,
you're thinking in,
really, the liter range.
And if you're thinking about
how much fluid it would take
to fill a swimming
pool, now you're talking
in the tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands
or even millions of liter range.